you know when we pulled up to the beach
house yeah and her wig was here
and she didn't care she was hot let's
just check it
hi guys it's adriana petrine i'm mara
moosa it's your girl nella rose and
today we're going to be playing
glamour's bestie test
i complain about this every time i see
you guys faces
i don't know it though you do and you're
the worst that is to the worst
yeah i've come here i'm glamour to tell
you about yourself your trifling
because you don't even know that it
pisses me off you just keep doing it oh
oh oh she cheated
come on man it's not an essay ready yes
what did you guys get i put lightness
how did you put car
and you hate like i i don't like too
much club but then when i'm on holiday
that hotel room looks crazy
good thing we all respect each other you
don't respect my time
ever so that means i get the point no
you copied
myself gets the point because i'm being
biased
i have to get that even my enemies
should get it
i i might have to cut you off
literally she only drinks one thing ever
always she goes into events and she's
like
can i get her i'm going with
wait i'm interested to see what you guys
put this i put
vodka lemonade is it it's vodka
my babes you have there's so many this
is the one thing that really irritates
me like it gives me such
it but like you guys will get it i put
using vouchers to pay on a date or
looking for a bargain
is that right
hey i put like you know when you have to
ask me things that should already be
done oh i get it
but it doesn't give me the it oh thank
you what does give me is
one a paper coupon
i know my friends i get it
but on the first date
we all know let's write guys let's write
it down together yeah because you guys
should know this
i just want it to be erased oh just
honestly
this is it's getting too much for me now
dropping on stage i just put in this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i am a walking hypocrite okay
wow you wrote an essay or did you not
hurt the whole couple's channel and
then doing the breakup videos afterwards
i would never post
coming soon well i went with um taking
her man back for cheating i feel like
you said you'll never be but remember we
just had the chat recently
of the past yeah i said that was the
past it's not my future
five times i think she's let now dating
a short guy i always say i would always
go for a tour guide but
how are you so adamant on this the type
changes
my type though not what i've gone out
with my type
but miriam you are a free spirit are you
ready
you really need this answer in it it's
not that hard though it's really simple
mine i've done it like love island that
was her tap on paper oh my god
[Applause]
i have it guys
[Music]
nobody's at her house and she cooks for
you and then she makes sure you've eaten
she'll be allowed sit down
basic hospital no but it's very motherly
guys she nearly canceled my birthday
because madam needs to be maintained no
i just had an appointment booked and
it's really hard like to get your
slaughter
she always has an appointment it's like
every weekend
equipment that's somewhere the toe the
heel they need to decide
the teeth time is in a good way though
not in a bad way yeah she's very it
keeps her organized she gets things done
she knows what she wants same thing
thanks guys
i can actually decide but guys you
actually have to answer the question
but if i can't but if you have to save
someone like you have to save your
family right now you just need to give
them
just give our answer i say never
question okay cool it's not it's fine
i'm not upset
cut the camera
yeah i would i think you've got a good
balance though i like your balance yeah
i'm trying
i'm trying a deal is guessing her up i'm
trying i'm trying
guys
[Applause]
i was just thinking like everyone's just
so funny you know
who pulled up to the beach house or
whatever yeah and the wig was here
her wig was so far back
and she didn't care she was hot let's
just check it
i take that personal that you asked that
nella honestly and
i don't like your tone
guys i'm the most emotional wreck
so cute though
mariam
i will cry of happiness story it's not
all sadness i don't think i've actually
seen you cry sad yeah you have
when you have i've never ever seen you
caught i can never even imagine her
crying
she's a silent one though she's not a
she's a
yeah and it drops
adios
[Laughter]
wow but i wow you said your own name
anyway because i have
i cuz wow
you